uh hey everyone this is Steve with
collider and I'm here in Park City at
our Sundance studio um I really want to
before we get started and talking about
your doc we want to give a huge thank
you to filo for being our sponsor we
would not be able to be here supporting
independent cinema without them um and
for people that don't know uh filo is
shattering barriers by placing the power
to Greenlight films in the hands of
creators and fans and you can learn a
lot more about them by visiting their
website film.
how are you guys doing doing okay happy
to be here yeah I was going to say I I
uh really uh you guys know it costs a
lot of money to do things especially
with movies and everything else I'm
hugely grateful to them for allowing us
to be here um so I have about a thousand
questions for the two of you uh I first
want to start with um a lot of people
know uh Mavis but they don't know the
documentary yet so how have you been
explaining it to friends and
family um so the last time I explained
it I was on uh the air I was in the
airport my layover on the way to here um
and met a very lovely woman who lives in
park not Parks who lives in Salt Lake
City and I said that we were um
investigating the legacy of a really
well-loved figure in Black technological
history um and then I said also that she
um is both not
real and also very real and hearts and
minds of people right Mavis Bean as a
really core childhood memory for a lot
of people and so I think um kind of
connecting um both like our Research
into like the making of like this very
like mythological figure like this
typing Prodigy um but then also at the
same time like trying to get deeper into
the meat of like the labor behind
creating who she became a lot of that
labor was like done by a black F who we
felt like didn't entirely get what she
deserved or we weren't sure if she did
and we wanted to check we wanted to know
for sure because yeah the impact the
impact of her work was so great um and
so it kind of follows Jasmine and I on a
bit of a goose chase um to try and get
get an interview with the the woman who
lent her face and body to yeah the
embodiment of nasika and Rene L Bron so
one of the things is making any film is
very challenging and I'm curious how
tough was it to get this off the ground
in terms of getting some sort of
financing and how much was it you guys
just doing it on your own you know what
I mean like yeah totally um I'd love to
talk about the process I mean the film
is all about process um I think it's
worth naming this was in development for
two years just with me applying and
applying to different grants and it was
truly the moment that I found Olivia as
a collaborator and she agreed to join
the project and also uh my producer
Getty fine at Bell Moon um it was
actually like there's power in numbers
so the moment that they joined this
project it felt like everything was
getting green lit um it also was in 2020
at a really contentious time where a lot
of film institutions were like maybe we
will listen to what these black
filmmakers have to say um so I think
that was super advantageous to us and we
you know we we are aware of the stakes
of this project and the fact that um it
was probably green lit given the brutal
ation that black people were facing in
2020 one of the things about this
project is I really felt your obsession
while I was watching and um did you can
you look back on it like did you feel
the obsession because it felt like you
know what I mean like I I felt like I
don't want I don't know how like you
were almost losing yourself a little bit
in in in that's the way I felt while
watching it in trying to get answers and
make you know what I mean no totally uh
we have a interview subject in the film
who's a writer Shavon reinh Halt and she
uses this term in her writing trans
fictions to describe what was happening
there um which is essentially an
obsession and yeah it got really meta uh
the space and the headquarters that you
see in the film wasn't just a location
for shooting it was truly where we were
working um and so I was editing you know
proof of Concepts in the exact same
headquarters um and it's been about 5
years of talking about Mavis Beacon
every day I didn't know the process
would take this long and I'm happy to
say I actually really love Mavis Beacon
um and I'm never sick of talking about
the character well one of the things I
think that a lot when I mentioned you
guys were coming in for this dock
everyone or a lot of people knew the
typing software or had heard of her and
I'm just sort of curious like for people
that don't realize can you sort of talk
about the impact of this software and
Mavis in especially in in like the black
community but but also just in general
it was a very impactful piece of
software yeah no Mavis beon teaches was
typing I think sold like maybe 15
million copies crazy number on the order
of millions don't don't quote me on 15
when they stopped tracking the numbers
it was 10 million so given the amount of
time and the fact that people are still
free downloading you know Mavis Beacon
online Source archive.org um you know it
came out in around
1987 I think was the first like launch
where people were able to order it
online and I think there's just one New
York Times review and it was flying off
the shelves and it was at a time where
people were really like getting used to
the concept of computers being inside of
their homes and not just being things
that scientists use or people in
business used it was around the same
time that like um Apple had their like
crazy Super Bowl commercial for like
1984 like there was a lot of just like
Collective Consciousness about like oh
my God computers are here the internet
is coming um and Mavis Beacon was a lot
of people's like first like entry point
to like becoming a part of modernity in
that way and so like for whether it was
school AG children or like working
adults who were like okay shoot like I
have a new skill that I need to learn
because of the like enormous popularity
of the software from like the late 80s
all the way until the late 90s and
potentially like a little bit more into
the early 2000s it was like the main way
that people really like came to know
like came to embody themselves
physically and like engage with
computers in a way that empowered them
like to go from like hun and pecking to
like really like being all like Maestro
on the keys is a very like affirming
experience that makes you feel like okay
I'm not like just some like schmuck who
doesn't know how computers work sitting
in front of the computer like I actually
am in command of this machine sure and I
think like the feeling of being in
command of a machine that up until that
point was very alien to you um actually
plays a really big role in like your
confidence and your ability to like yeah
participate in the digital landscape in
a way that you couldn't before sure I I
I'm fascinated by the editing process
because and especially on a documentary
because that so talk a little bit about
how did you ultimately decide on some of
the on putting it together and the story
lines because you were there any story
lines that you ultimately pulled out how
did you like discover the right runtime
you know what I mean and and was there
and and this is part three but was there
anything that you were like we just this
is too personal or I can't include this
yeah that's a great question um the edit
it I would say been editing for 2 years
lightly and one year seriously um so our
editor John as Olivia and I were still
conducting the search and on the
investigation was ingesting the footage
and he put together an assembly that was
chronological and I hated it uh he was
great you know but it was just like it
was so much of us I thought we were so
obnoxious and Naval gazy I'm like we
have to cut a lot of this um and so
basically John uh fine Yen Cohen and I
at the start of summer had an Upstate
Retreat and and we just started arcing
out like how could this go how can we
break up this linear thing um and still
have it be reflective and truthful of
what we experienced uh what's
interesting is that the actual like um
the interviews that you see with the
people who are involved in making the
software all of that does unfold
chronologically in terms of like plot
lines it's hard to believe uh I'm it's a
personal doc I you know I'm a very
emotional person uh and so we actually
cut some of the scenes with me crying
just because we're like this is a bummer
um and it was just like within the span
of an hour and a half it's like you can
only cry so many times before people are
just like okay wrap it
up yeah so I would say we cut out some
of the crying um the idea of Olivia
going back to school I'll let you speak
to that but you know she's coming of age
and questioning going back to school and
that was truly unfolding with the dock
um and so when we ended filming you know
Olivia got into college and it was a
great heroic story of like yay back to
education um but you know you can speak
to this it didn't actually reflect where
Olivia was at in her thinking about
school so we opened that up to kind of
reflect this other thing where she
departs from Academia um and I'm really
excited about that plot line because I
do think we're so used to seeing these
like brilliant young black fem who you
know are geniuses and go off to school
and I think Olivia is a genius and is
brilliant um but doesn't source that
that Brilliance in academic institution
and all that so I'm just really great to
see that like glad yeah I feel like um
there's definitely like trying to figure
out like what our character like arcs
would be in terms of like making the
film make sense because we realized
quickly like the ark wouldn't be us
talking to Renee and so we had to like
kind of go on our journey I mean we were
going on Journeys internally but like in
order to kind of create a sense of
satisfaction I think um it was helpful
to kind of have our own like internal
worlds be like starting someplace else
ending someplace else and I think like
yours is kind of like very like
emotional in terms of like getting to to
a point of Peace acceptance for me
Olivia definitely accepts things sooner
than I do in the film versus I'm like
fully just growing up like I go from 18
to 20 I'm 22 now we started this when I
was 18 I like I bleach my brows I like
turn 21 I get Co a few times like
there's a sense of like real like
several like personal just Revolutions
of like growing up very quickly happen
in the space I think and I think also at
the same time
um I learned a lot about
like learning and like what Cur like
what curiosity I think meant to me I
think after like encountering just like
the learning style of like being on set
and being in an active investigation and
like pulling pulling up these threads
and like having to be like a real Auto I
think in just in the process of working
the idea of going back to school
afterwards and being in an environment
that does not necessarily like encourage
creativity or like individual thought
and like kind of wants you to like be
like um not a not a robot that's not
quite Fair because I was applying to BFA
programs that were interested in
artistic craft but not necessarily
like it was just the vibe wasn't hitting
the vibe wasn't hitting anymore um and
my goals changed a lot I was just going
to say like I think that college and
school is very important especially for
some degrees and
ways it's a lot of money that you
award yeah and I think Olivia is a
testament to like someone who I mean
she's doing theoretical work we're
citing Concepts that Olivia has coined
at the age of 18 you know this term of
like being a cyber Doula or someone who
stewards a healthy relationship to
technology she's being cited in the
texts of the people that we're
interviewing so I think it's kind of a
it's been really fascinating to watch
Olivia's growth and I think she has more
of an an outward Arc that you can track
by these moments in her life whereas
mine is an internal Arc of
denial so I definitely want to talk
about the fact that uh and like the doc
does such a great job at really pulling
back uh who Mavis Beacon was and Renee
and everything else but uh for people
that don't realize let's just touch on
real quick uh Mavis is a creation of
three white men and who you know saw a
someone saw a woman put on the cover so
a could you sort of talk about that and
B do you think that the software without
like you take Renee off that software
and maybe it's nothing you know it's
like Rene's face was so integral in this
software's success it's very true um
actually there were other typing
softwares on the market actually at the
same time that did have like kind of
spokes people but not necessarily a real
person on the cover like they would
invent like let me not I think I was
going to be like Lisa I don't think the
name was Lisa but like there they were
they they had competitors um and there
was a big sense I think at the outset
when they released the software and
people were a bit like Jarred by the
presence of like a black woman on the
shelves like they didn't they weren't
selling well initially um and then and
then there was a shift to all of a
sudden they were getting like so many
orders they couldn't handle it um and I
think there's definitely a sense of
like um a lot of people would like call
and like ask for Mavis Beacon to like
come speak at their school and like give
like very like there was a sense of like
this is a celebrity endorsement of a
software um and that that's why she's
like Incorporated and not that this was
like a figure of marketing it didn't
really they didn't really pivot their
marketing strategy to being very clear
that she was fake until after the
lawsuit and after like it became like oh
maybe it's a bit like maybe we've given
too much power Away by allowing like
this person who's like not part of the
company to like be so synonymous with
the S software but there's definitely
like um I think yeah the ability to
accept this like introduction of new
technology into your house by having
like a friendly face and one that many
people thought was like beautiful and
like dressed in businesswear and like
and it goes it can play either way I
think what's really brilliant about the
marketing of it especially when you're
like late 80s you know you've got the
Cosby's on television there's this image
of like a black middle class um and so
it's like look if you're Pro black
you're like that's a black woman on the
cover I'm buying it if you also have a
contentious relationship to Blackness
she's in a subservient position so she's
there to help you do a thing um so I do
think it was a bit of a um Mandy Harris
Williams our interview subject described
it as a culture gem uh I think she's a
culture Gem and I don't think we would
be having this conversation if she
wasn't black and you know I have a lot
of feelings about that casting choice
but ultimately I'm really grateful and
the whole reason I was interested in
this project was like we don't have
enough role models of black people in
technology like there are so many of our
stories at the onset of building these
things that just weren't accounted for
and are not archived so that's where I
was like whether or not she's real I
need all the role models I can get so
let's flush this out a bit and figure
out who the real person is yeah and like
to like a prioritization or just like to
hold in equal weight kind of these soft
skills and it's like whether or not Rene
was like in the process of like coding
the thing like not necessarily but but
the factor of the matter is is that her
presence in the labor that she performed
like are a reason why the work was
successful and I think women black women
and and just in general who might be
working in technology and are in kind of
more like what is considered softer
roles that are either like more people
facing or like are solving different
kinds of problems that might not be
technical but are still problems that
get in the way of the work being done
often times like are discredited and are
not given like the same level of
priority and respect that their peers
who might be assumed to be more skilled
at technical things because of pchy are
given more respect in those ways so I
think it's also cool that we're able to
like like yes this is a role model in
technology history despite not being a
computer scientist one of the things I'm
sure you've noticed by now is I'm trying
not to give away anything from the doc
uh you know I'm trying to promote while
not you know what I mean um but one of
the things that you guys did in the doc
is you you know had Tik Tok things
videos like it it it it's a it feels new
and fresh can you sort of talk about the
aesthetic and you know the importance of
having like modern social Clips inside
all the footage yeah I think um I've
described this film as kind of the the
baby of somebody who watches like too
much like hate watches True Crime while
scrolling on Tik Tok learning about
critical race Theory so it's like all of
those things are present in this film um
I think so much we attribute you know
it's deeply referential uh Olivia has
encouraged me I'm like are we are we
citing too many sources and she's like
no this is just a part of like feminist
practice of like citing the sources that
come before you and so being a Lage it's
we're part of a lineage and so I'm
really grateful not only to shout out
you know um the Sadia Hartman's and
Cheryl Den that are inspiring this work
but also like the black vloggers and Tik
tokers who are putting an incredible
amount of time and research um into this
and also you know um I love the phrase
like the revolution must be like
irresistible they're sexy and I think
that people online the black internet
they're so good at taking these really
difficult subjects and adding humor to
it and so that was something where we're
like we know we're making a film that
can potentially have a really really bad
ending and a really sad ending so we
want to approach this with as much
levity as possible um not going to spoil
the ending I it's definitely it's not as
sad and bad as we were prepared for um
but we're dealing with some Prett pretty
heavy themes here and I think the
internet just has a way of making that
medicine go down a bit easier yeah there
was definitely a version of the film
that we tried to stay away from in terms
of like yeah searching for like a
missing black woman like black women go
missing all the time and like no one
really looks for them not in the way
that would like guarantee their safety
and like being brought home in a
reasonable time frame and I think um
there is a sense of like while we were
filming like there was a lot of like
just even like news about like women who
like would be like going missing or just
like it was it was a kind of time where
that was very top of mind as well and so
we're like how do we talk about this and
be like not like super depressing and
also like acknowledge the fact that like
we keep us safe and like all of these
people are very comfortable saying like
oh like we haven't heard from her in a
while but like I'm sure she's fine and
we are like actually like no like why
don't you just look and why hasn't
anyone looked and come to the
realization that like maybe like yeah
like maybe we are the ones we were
waiting
for um so yeah uh I'm just about out of
time with you and I have to wrap but I'm
just going to say Obviously you guys
were very successful working together so
is it one of these things where um you
know are there other ideas that we want
to pursue do you see what I mean I mean
Olivia does have a life to live I I mean
look she's been and it has made this
project so much more thorough um also I
think like we are truly family at this
point and like our friendship was not
just for the movie like we're that's my
sister so and there's also so many other
Mysteries we've uncovered so look if
someone wants to fund us like I have
questions we have a lot of Pop Culture
questions what was artha Franklin
filming on that camera where did Hattie
McDaniel's Oscar go was Betty bloop a
black woman um so yeah if anyone wants
to fund that there's absolutely room for
a spin-off series um but I think we're
going to sleep a little bit maybe
allegedly I don't think you have the
ability to shut down I I watching you in
this movie I'm like I I think that uh
you you're not shutting down no you'll
probably see us um at the next Sundance
yeah I'm like I I have a well listen I
really want to say congrats on the film
and congrats on getting in Sundance and
I really do I'm assuming it's for sale
or is it it's a you know it's an
interesting thing neon they're sales
company and this is a very unique
project that they entered at the
production level it sounds like there's
a strong possibility of a theatrical run
and then we're figuring out where to
stream it that sounds awesome yeah thank
you so much for speaking to us and your
thoughtful questions uh listen I I
really say congrats and I'm so happy you
guys made it and um thank you for being
at Sundance and to everyone watching
thank you uh for supporting collider
blah blah blah but mostly I want to give
again a huge thank you to filo for being
our sponsor because with them we are
able to talk to you uh about your
documentary thank you fil thank
youer on that note have a great day
everyone
thanks